my secure cyberspace was
and inspired by the
national strategy to
space in that strategy the president
refers to each citizen being responsible
to secure his her or her own part of
cyberspace the my secure cyberspace is
really not just a game but it is a
series of games that are embedded within
an online experience so when children
launch the game they're really launching
themselves into cyberspace and they're
taking the role of being a future
Carnegie cadet they get to engage in
exploratory learning and the great thing
about the game it's a game that teaches
but the the teaching part the learning
part is sometimes seamless to the kids
they're having fun and at the same time
they're learning
you